no prize is forgetting who this kitchen
is catering for
full english coming up and the chef and
owner here is grateful for his first
and possibly only customers of the day
the four candles bar and restaurant in
lorette de mar catalonia
is used to catering for thousands of uk
visitors at this time of year
kovid19 has changed that and it's tough
last year every single table was full
the kitchen working full blast lots of
customers coming turning people away
because we were that busy
and this year this there's just a few
people thank you
orders are delivered to some of the
dwindling number of britons coming to
this beach town since covert cases
began to rise in catalonia after the
nationwide lockdown in spain
but matthew dixon decided to press ahead
with his 50th birthday trip
as long as we all take our own
protection and take
responsibility for ourselves and
everybody else we should be all right
but everywhere now there's hand
sanitizer masks they really can only
take your masks off when you're when
you're dining really or drinking you
know
walk on the beach in the absence of
british accents is noticeable
and business owners are simply grateful
that some spanish and french
tourists who traditionally make up the
biggest numbers here each summer
are still willing to come helping to
fill at least some of the dining tables
and bedrooms at one of loret de mar's
biggest hotel complexes
stay here at the moment and you'll
pretty much have the pool to yourself
but the reality for the hotel and its
staff is depressing
in a town where tourism is the only real
industry
when the news one week goes
uh appears that the the the the pandemi
starts again in a second way this is
very frustrating really
because cancellation arrives you know
we have we are 350 workers
in a normal season now that working just
52. at this time of year these streets
are usually packed with tourists
but covered cases in catalonia have put
so many off
despite lorette de mar having barely
been touched by the virus
many here wonder if the town and many
others will be able to bounce back
michelle clifford sky news catalonia